seem. I'm not going crazy.
Here the copter has taken off again. It's [ __ ] unclear where
it's taking off from. What a [ __ ] clown he is. Both. Out of
the blue , [ __ ]. Both. What a [ __ ] thing. [ __ ] your mother.
What technology has come to. Why the [ __ ] do we work while
driving, damn it? He'd better control the [ __ ] copter. Gruzava
and that's it. ABOUT! Oh, [ __ ]! And the cops knock him down,
imagine. This is some kind of machine gun burst, damn it. Oh,
what a [ __ ] mess, [ __ ]. It turns out he's a [ __ ], it turns
out. Oh,
[ __ ], the cops missed, [ __ ]. [ __ ]. He flew there again,
[ __ ], into that [ __ ] thicket. Here's another one, [ __ ],
[ __ ]. Here he is, another [ __ ].
Why the [ __ ] do I have to hear this over the speaker, [ __
] hell?
Well yeah, we
[ __ ] went fishing, damn.
And I say, I spent the money on
work. And he spent it.
Well, [ __ ], it's not about drones. It's mined. There's a [
__ ] dick there.
This is a mess. This is a mess.
Which one is this? Eleventh.
Eleventh. Look what's happening. I do n't even know what just
exploded. This is probably dialectical. But this one turns out
to be it . I'm
not the one taking off the lids.